[Music]
and then my name is saundra Woodruff I
am a senior graduating this may and from
the school of general studies I was on
tour at the Backstreet Boys
I played a little Taylor Swift I played
with the LL Cool J I've had some great
experiences my decision to come to
Columbia
the school of general studies was really
based on one line said that the school
of general studies just a place for
non-traditional students to be
integrated into a traditional setting
and for me that was the most powerful
part and I wanted to always complete my
education so once I finally got into
Columbia and seeing how you can just
kind of pick apart music the kind of
access do you have the people who are
thinking outside of the box of music the
fact that I now mix neuroscience with
music and it's still applicable in pop
music and that's the type of
relationship that I've found by being at
Columbia that it doesn't just have to be
I can play an instrument but I can use
it in so many different ways in life the
program for the daughters of Harlem
working in sound is a program where we
work with young young women of color and
we bring them to Columbia's campus and
teach them how to create music or play
an instrument and the end product after
the eight hours is for them to have a
finished song or production or sound
that they can take with them so after I
graduate from Columbia I am moving back
home to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania to open
a music facility with my two really
really good friends and the main thing
is it's going to be a place where you
can kind of incubate your band or your
group or you can kind of take your music
career more seriously but it's going to
be designed in a way that empowers
everyone who walks in to feel like what
they have to offer matters there's a
direct correlation to the effects that I
saw in the program for our daughters of
Harlem just the way that their faces lit
up
and they felt like okay I I do have a
voice in this space and that's the same
feeling that I want to create in
limelight with my two friends is you
know I do have a voice in this space
[Music]